hey guys Ryan right over here and I'm
Dan Seibert over here so we're gonna
check out the trailer that people have
been asking me for quite some time now
Mortal Kombat X story mode gameplay I
have this sent over to me this is like
the Johnny Cage one I think let's check
out what all the [ __ ] hype is about
hashtag death hype know what [ __ ] is
that are you just starting it off with a
book
Oh destination so done that's an easy
for me always
if by always that was there like like us
banner e6 good jokes
[Music]
oh all right
you have the rendezvous coordinates
forage enforced from there we access the
portals of rated sky temple where
there's an angry former elder Gallatin
Devils waiting for us
God portals flying demons blind guys
with magic swords the world has changed
for the worse we do not expel shinnok
from grated apples he needs to poison
orthros life force the jinn said and
we're not going to let that happen
can't you I appreciate the major
allowing us Julia we're happy to help
pick ships only ass back to that around
oh [ __ ] alarm is going off you can wake
up now
Oh scorpion
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm so [ __ ] totally into this right
now so it's a hybrid of gameplay and
cinematic so you just press the button
just a few quick time events as long as
the game is not comprised a lot of it
[Music]
nice
he doesn't care about anyone whatever
expendable man
[Music]
[Music]
sub-zero's dick is as hard as ice
diggin it
[Music]
you do nothing that okay you didn't jump
out so no no fish is hot
it's okay she'll be fine yeah get it a
little ahead of yourself
fortune ah here we go
[Music]
but I'm super psyched whatever man first
level you got to get used to it more
beans on fighting back yeah oh great
[Music]
that really make me splits of weapon
dude every hit sounds phenomenal yeah
it's like there's a certain level of
[Music]
I gotta get back to the chopper so yeah
[Music]
that was Sonya Blade I feel stupid oh no
[Music]
where's magic sword dude oh that was
unpleasantly cold fun yeah
[Music]
but [ __ ] hey players like oh why did
why did subs yes yeah
level one man you did it he solved the
riddle I'm watching this I'm like I am
never going to be this good
ah
[Music]
and that's how they like a delayed
reaction death elected better when we
fought on the same side back story okay
we fared better than the bed until mr.
Fang Shih knuckle answer for
I'm into it
sweet I'm into it so there is there a
story mode version that you could play
as well because I remember like tech and
had something like that we're like okay
you can just play match up like an
arcade game but then you could also like
take a character and go through a whole
story I think that's what this is right
I just wanted to make sure my brain knew
what I was getting that was a story it's
been a while since I've played a Mortal
Kombat storyline it's been mostly just
vs. and I'm not sure how nine was but
this is probably one of the better like
even just right off the bat you know
story wise it felt better than most
fighting game storylines which is like
hey you in this area that we're gonna
fight it
[ __ ] you and yeah I guess like what you
do and then you fight that's what I
thought this game was gonna consist of
yeah this is like actual story
progression it's a city and flying off
of a hell ya know that's pretty crazy
like even the levels are adjusting to
the story itself in that sense like what
if you choose scorpion as a character
and then you go through his store I've
bet you there's two stories well I'm
hoping because like ya wonder if I want
to be Scorpion and sub-zero and go the
other way I'm hoping that they're gonna
do two different paths like this
quote-unquote good side in this corner
coke bad side right right and so they
have like different victory you're a
totally different story endings and all
that sort of stuff that's what I would
hope for okay so there's the Mortal
Kombat movies sure Mortal Kombat
annihilation the best interpretation of
Mortal Kombat ever of course on that
quote me on that
well and then there is the web series
Mortal Kombat legacy which people have
been talking about making it to a movie
for the longest [ __ ] time but this
one I like how it started off with
Johnny Cage he's not an actor he's like
a mercenary or something whatever I
don't know it's futuristic dystopia kind
of vibe going on I am gravitated more
towards scene cuz they've been talking
about making another movie the studio's
like oh we're gonna do another one
to another where it's like that for many
[ __ ] years and I think to take a
unique approach they should do something
along the lines of what this story is
offering that's kind of in the future
the world's falling apart one thing I
want to say real quick is that like
Johnny Cage compared to its Sub Zero and
scorpion looks like a blade you think so
I'd like I don't know if that's like
final graphics that unfortunately look
to me looks like xbox 360 version
FairPoint because like I've seen much
better graphics from like dying light
the graphics look incredible on the mat
kind of looked like hey mm that's fair
you want us to come out my April yeah I
mean they still got time so it could
just be an early thing it still looks
[ __ ] badass though well scorpion is
like a lot of people's favorite
characters never spend a lot of time on
making sure that scorpion looks oh yeah
dude and he does you express I mean come
on - get over here get over here the
fighting scenes are pretty cool - I like
the cinematograph and I think the
gameplay with the cinematic graphics
actually match up pretty well I hate
watching cinematic effects from like I
wish they allowed us to do that in the
King ya know it's like they match up
pretty damn well and I I'm really
impressed that's it for today if you
guys are new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects dan has a
gaming channel that cyber channel plays
games against gaming channel and you can
follow us on Instagram Twitter and
Facebook yeah maybe we'll play Mortal
Kombat X on the gym mat Casey
hmm hey he has two first names oh cool
hey guys love the channel you guys Rock
would like to ask a question why do porn
sites offer to share to Facebook anyway
we love a shout out to my youtube
channel I do movie reviews mostly by the
way tell Brandi she is super sweet
thanks for the support guys okay a lot
of information here Horn sites well porn
it's you know there's stuff like
pornhub.com you to you porn calm redtube
calm this do they seriously have an
option to like share to Facebook yeah no
they don't
yeah they do I do oh then I always label
know what I know much about your
facebook profile yeah
there's people like me out there and
that's why your YouTube channel I've
actually seen you before dude you really
I have seen this guy before normally
that's a joke but he does movie reviews
and he had an interesting setup I wonder
if it's changed hey he adjusted the
angle like I told him to nice now change
your focus yeah now change your focus
your focus is oh look yeah you're out of
focus right no but and your audio could
be a slight bit better it's improved
already dude [ __ ] keep crushing it
keep crushing it dude keep crushing it
you always got to keep keep improving
and don't forget man don't forget you
got a shaved head but ladies will still
like it if there's a little bit of pubic
hair down there because you don't want
it to be like oh your ball up here and
then your ball down there it's just too
much baldness it's like me it's like
when Neil woke up from the matrix mm-hmm
you know my round ball he was sure he
was like no hair at all yeah that'd be
weird
yeah be weird so yeah get some pubes and
continue the YouTube journey